thank you
[Music]
Mattel you guys ever heard of Mattel one
of the best toy companies in the world
they make movies now they're in the
movie Biz really we're getting in the
business of offering seventeen thousand
dollars to someone
who can play UNO cuatro for four hours
per day wow why you're gonna play UNO
yeah but I'll play with tiger right now
four hours is kind of long that sounds
also long ass time by yourself too kind
of boring how many days how long do you
think you can play by yourself don't you
need like an opponent you need people to
play with I I could only play for like
30 minutes and then I got I get bored
yeah yeah so oh is it because they want
them to play
no no okay so so if you're selected for
this job you get four thousand four
hundred forty four dollars for four
weeks from September 13th to October 7th
and if selected you will be working from
2 to 6 p.m four days out of the week no
agent's gonna play that here are your
duties you must be comfortable with
interviews and appearances hope hoping
to create and start social content for
various Uno games starring on live
streams playing Uno cuatro with brand
creators
being friendly willing to ask strangers
to play the game being able to teach
strangers to play the game okay you need
to sit for long periods lift and carry
up to 50 pounds so you need to carry
heavy loads and set up playing tables
and Tents so they're basically turning
you into a street team yes it's a
marketing gimmick obviously it's not
it's gonna flop in Asia
four is like six six oh yeah nobody
likes so if they go four four four
four they're gonna be like why would I
play that you want me to die they don't
even have fourth floors on hospitals
really yep
they go one to three and then five all
the way to the top my hotels are like
that too is your mom very strict on the
floor or yeah anytime there's a there's
a number four in anything my mom is like
nope it's because four also sounds like
death like in Chinese same with Japanese
but it was my favorite number growing up
yeah like for a suit and then death is
what's the difference what's the
difference you guys most of the tone
Chinese is so hard the tone changes
everything yeah same words that's what
they sound like can't they just change
the word aliens they should change the
word huh it'll be easier
again so they can hear it it's four and
then yeah it's like saying death and so
so death wait I don't know which one is
which I don't like this record label how
long do you guys do you
30 minutes yeah I think we've played it
for a minute because I'll [__] smash
on taika and I'm bored it depends if
they hire like a banging hot girl to do
this I think a lot of dudes will
suddenly be playing Uno a long time yeah
that's true I think they'll be drawing
[__] drawing 12 or whatever
okay okay to make the game longer more
cards I got more cards [__] it's like
those um
dumb activities just really entertaining
why do you think they hire them for
[__] internet poker true your
attention is long internet Blackjack
they're not even for sick of cars the
car's already sick they put a hot girl
the Carly the sicker that's true they
always get titty ladies for those things
ladies all the time is everywhere all
the time umbrella girls at the car show
they don't exist anymore oh really they
took them out of F1 I feel like it's
easy parking because feminists
complained well because they're ugly
that's they got the F1 umbrella girls
fired and they never wanted to get fired
all these beautiful [__] can't even
get jobs now yeah why do feminists hate
beautiful girls because they were oh I
don't know I don't want to keep talking
what do you think
Colleen's next isn't it women
empowerment to see other beautiful women
just make it in life not if they're
prettier than me it's to restrict access
to the benefits that they cannot
themselves enjoy oh [__] someone [__]
is writing a Manifesto
someone's gonna shoot a muscle up and
leave a letter
all I'm saying is they get paid really
good there's Booth girls too at car
shows oh yeah yeah
oh are you laughing Around Tires and
[__] there's also CEO girls at car shows
no there's not yeah but they're not hot
I've never seen one yeah what have you
ever seen have you ever seen a CEO girl
at all they don't it was that one girl
Elizabeth Holmes she was a big time CEO
girl who's that the scammer yeah
the biotech scammer
oh yeah oh that girl Caroline uh Ellis
she was the CEO what does she do I'm
kind of wrestling for being an FTX and
scamming people I remember that
so the popular ones oh her yeah the
popular ones are the ones that get
caught for be doing some shady stuff
I think that's probably who they want
but they can't explicitly say that um
the Uno people you know people I have to
be able to fit a double D bra yeah like
how could you sneak that in how could
you add the parameter and undetected how
could you say it how could you phrase it
Jesus well it it's like what Hollywood
did with casting right
it's like they don't quite say in the
character descriptions now that she's
hot but they talk around it a a young
Charming young that's true yeah they'll
do the Talk of the Town put together put
together don't you sometimes hate how
primitive you are
I can't fight it they will do that for
like you said for castings for guy
castings they will say like must be
charismatic but they're talking about
tall handsome man yeah they're talking
about tall handsome white guy or it
looks white but is ethnically ambiguous
somehow will you put them in anything
yeah
they can't write an ethnic guy if they
want an ethnic role they can't they just
can't write uh tall handsome white yeah
they can't say they're looking for a
wagon what if they go like Brad Pitt
look-alike
that's that's good that's messed up no
that's that's a high standard
what if there are cows like it feels
like
what if they're casting for I don't know
like let's say old school World War II
movie and it's just so happens to take
place in Germany and then they're like
um we only want a certain type of Aryan
looking dudes bro there were a lot of
people who complained that there weren't
enough black people in Oppenheimer
who complained about that well is
Oppenheimer going to be able to win an
Oscar because of that because you know
what they just did with the Oscar stuff
oh yeah you have to like start amount of
disabled certain amount of minority
certain amount of percents yeah so I
don't know if Oppenheimer even met that
look if it will even be nominated that's
so [__] crazy they should they should
have had a Oppenheimer B uh gay black
lesbian yeah or all black cast
Oppenheimer I'd watch that
I want to do all black cast Last Samurai
oh that'd be tight that'll be cool I
think I think that if you do all One
race cast movies I think that I'll just
have good variation for like like you
said last time it's like imagine Soul
Plane but Samurai Chinese yeah all
Chinese white clue oh wait there already
did that one all white clue would be
good
you know there's already sick ass movies
or that that potential movies of like
different characters that are black or
whatever Asian but like instead of just
doing like the lazy thing and making
like a I don't know like a Marvel hero a
Asian guy or whatever like termination
yeah or like they could just
read like create a new store or like do
a story that already exists that's sick
as [__]
like they want to do the lucrative thing
yeah there's like there's like a black
Samurai
um that's that was an anime but it's
actually a real story where he was like
um he was enslaved by Portuguese uh
Traders and then he came to Japan and
then he be he he I guess like he stayed
in Japan he became a Samurai and I'm
like that's a real story that's [__]
sick I think there's just too much
context he can't get mad at it yet yeah
what else you got yeah okay
um yeah pictures
there's a
there's a store there's actually you
know the the the story of uh The Last
Samurai where there was a white guy that
became a samurai yeah dude I was so mad
because I was like how dare you [__]
whitewash this [__] and then I studied
it and it was actually it was a story of
two different Europeans that became
samurais one was a British guy and one
was a french guy and then they ended up
becoming Samurai in Japan and uh and I
was like okay so uh so they didn't
whitewash it they actually combined a
bunch of actual stories yeah it's funny
because a lot of these things where you
want more Original Stories it's a put
your money where your mouth is situation
because even if you want to make it
that's great how who do you get to
invest in it who's gonna put the money
up yeah yeah so if nobody's willing to
do that then you don't who's gonna buy
the tickets too yeah do it right so that
just happened with Scarlett Johansson
right she was supposed to play like uh I
think a trans character yeah and they
basically said you're not trans so [__]
you and then they pulled the funding for
the movie and then he's not gonna get
made now so that story won't get told
yeah I won't get told exactly then now
anyone else that's like oh I have a
trans story they're like well that's the
presidents yeah so it's gonna be really
hard they're like we don't want Scarlett
Johansson we don't want any Asians to
play a trans story or Hawaiians that's
why it's dope when like let's say like
Justin Chun wanted to tell that story
like Blue by you it's like yeah so he's
gonna put up
the funds to make it happen so it's like
you still have to get to that point of
like put up the funds it's [__] dope
when someone does it but most of the
time no one's doing they're just
complaining about it they're just saying
it's not there
um interesting or a great quote from
Denzel about all this stuff and he was
talking about I don't think he by the
way thinks one way or another
necessarily but he was talking about how
you know if you're gonna direct like a
movie about like a black guy for example
he's like
um the way that like he runs his calm
through the hot water I saw that it was
a great culture it's about culture right
you can't you know a director is needs
to infuse the movie with the culture and
I don't know if that someone will be
capable of doing that unless they did a
lot of research or whatever he wasn't
even saying it one way or another but
like it's more likely that they'll be
able to do that if they are if they had
that experience that made so much sense
because he's like that's why this
director makes these movies yeah and
that director makes these ones that's
like they're not trying to mix them up
yeah yeah he's like Score says he's
making all these movies because you know
all his family right he knows the world
yeah yeah but you can't just like oh
this movie needs a [__] tongue and
for no reason let me just put one in
there but then he doesn't understand the
Tongan experience he's like yeah it
makes sense
but I do know the donut experience and I
tell you you brought a lot of delicious
donuts and I think we all can relate on
a good donut so I think we need to make
more movies that everyone can just
relate to yeah like who can hate a
[__] movie about Donuts yeah well who
would watch a movie about them
that's the funding to make a movie about
Donuts dude
looking for a lot of different movies
that shouldn't have been funded yeah I
could give you crispy Kreme
big donut
Krispy Kreme Dunkin Donuts the Cambodian
Mafia winchells winchells they're kind
of dying but I think they're down
that's why man it comes down to like if
you're really complaining that you want
this thing then help crowdfund it but
you're not donating nothing we gotta
make donuts you're just mad once the
movies a really good title at least it's
really good donut the movies Donuts
is the main character a human being or
alive
it's a mixture like cool world or he's a
baker who can't even make a donut
because he's [__] an idiot he's down
on his luck he's down on his luck his
wife divorced but in by the end of the
movie he learns how to make donuts yeah
and then everyone's like that's the best
donuts I've ever had yeah those trains
just so that we could win an Oscar today
yeah because then the percents go up
foreign